je sais pas si vous êtes un gros fan de
l'actu des smartphones si vous suivez ça
depuis quelques années oui ou non
d'ailleurs diplomate tout de suite en
commentaire on commence directement par
un petit commentaire
mais il ya des marques s'associent à
d'autres marques notamment des marques
de smartphones qui vont s'associer à des
marques d'automobiles pour quelles
raisons mais simplement parce que vous
avez un adepte comme en termes de
performances en termes de puissance en
termes d'élégance ça peut paraître très
marketing dit comme ça ça l'est d'une
certaine manière mais de l'autre côté
savez les valeurs communes et dans
toutes ses marques
vous avez notamment one plus que
s'associent avec mclaren mclaren sont
des voitures d'exception qui dit votre
d'exception dit très très belle finition
des beaucoup de puissance de ta forme
ans et l'idée avec ce mois de plus cet
été pro mclaren il ya tellement de trucs
à la fois fini par me down et bien c'est
tout simplement de parler effectivement
d'un smartphone d'exception déjà le voit
ne plus citer pro de base non mclaren
est plutôt bien même plutôt très bien
très intéressant et vous faire un petit
comparé entre tous les modèles qui
sortent et cette année parce que ils
prennent un peu de mal à savoir sur quel
one plus il faut aller je vous explique
ça d'ici quelques instants
l'idée de la vidéo d'aujourd'hui je vous
le présente et je vous ai déjà parlé du
one piece est très pro donc j'ai pas
vous refaire une énième vidéo du moins
de plus cet éperon par contre ce qui
m'intéresse
là dessus c'est de voir de quelle
manière est ce que le produit était
packagées pour certaines par contre le
one piece est trop loin de plus c'est
très pro et deviennent plus c'est des
pros de mclaren
elle n'est pas énorme ça surtout se
faire en terme de design en terme de
finition en termes de fonds d'écran en
termes d' icône mais ça pour bien s'en
rendre compte
regarder ensemble
[Musique]
il ya toute première chose c'est soins
qui a porté au packaging on est dans
cette couleur un peu orange papaye
orange plutôt a les oreilles du gourma
non pas se le faire comme ça je trouve
plutôt sympa alors c'est un parti pris
on retrouve les deux icônes des marques
one + mclaren
ça me ferait penser presque à une
bouteille de champagne ou une bouteille
de vin on savait qu'ils seraient mis
sous emballage comme ça dites moi ce que
vous pensez de la couleur en commentaire
ce que vous trouvez ça joli assez bien
pensé en fait ya toujours une expérience
au niveau des packagings domaine plus
lorsque vous ouvrez une boîte ronde plus
c'est pas forcément et pour toutes les
marques et bien chaque fois vous avez
plusieurs niveaux de lecture à chaque
fois que vous devrez regarder la up
vous ouvrez et vous tombez sur le slogan
never sitl qui est écrit ici c'est
toujours bien pensée la façon dont c'est
fait et c'est ça que j'aime beaucoup
dans les zones boxing one plus on arrive
ensuite sur une deuxième boîte là on se
retrouve avec du carbone dans le carbone
ça rappelle tout de suite la vitesse ça
rappelle la légèreté qu'on va retrouver
dans les voitures de course notamment
dans l'est dans les formules en carbone
qui est plutôt sympa on retrouve
toujours la couleur papaye en dessous tu
n'as qu'une petite flèche en bas nous
indiquent qu'il ya autre chose en
dessous mais ça on ne reviendra après on
se retrouve toujours avec ce petit
orange papaye ou en plus mclaren on voit
qu'on peut venir hop le prendre juste
comme ça on l'enlève et là on se
retrouve sur le smartphone alors on
continue toujours
vous voyez le smartphone la petite
flèche ici là pour venir l'enlever on se
retrouve en dessous avec les caps pas
mal tout ça c'est rigolo en fait au
niveau expérientiel comme c'est fait et
ici on retrouve le petit slogan facile
de bien lire never cycle alors qu'est ce
qu'on a ici un bloc de charge oui c'est
vraiment tout le travail qui est fait au
niveau du du design sur ce produit à sa
kia s'intéresse en fait c'est qu'ils
gardent les codes garde les mêmes
couleurs on a un smartphone qui est en
outre plus c'est très pro avec un peu
plus de performance parce qu'un peu plus
de ram mais sinon ce qui fait vraiment
l'intérêt et l'adn de ce produit c'est
tout simplement les codes couleurs c'est
l'univers mac line qui est assez
intéressant parce que sinon en lui-même
je vous dis vous qu'on en voit de plus
c'est très pro c'est quasiment la même
je sais pas si vous aimez dites moi
comment vous le trouvez vous le d'autres
smartphones c'est très typé c'est très
racée c'est très particulier mais c'est
pas mal on voit tout le travail qui a
été fait au niveau du
du design avec ce côté très élégant il
ya un vrai parti pris qui a pris sur ce
smartphone le choix des couleurs le
choix du design ou fait souligné le
module photo avec cette petite partie
orange et après ça va de plus cette
épreuve regarder même la la la petite
partie vous avez là la petite caméra
tough qui est plan qui sera cotée qui
est assez bien intégré c'est assez joli
elle devient même complètement invisible
par rapport aux moines +7 et pro si vous
comparez mclaren - de +7 et pro tout de
suite ça ressort beaucoup plus là c'est
vraiment mieux planquer ses tubes en
détail mais c'est assez sympa ensuite
qu'est ce qu'on met dans la boîte or ici
à ça j'aime bien le câble de charge
parti pris au niveau des couleurs alors
tous sont des câbles rouge
toujours du côté de chez swann plus là
c'est pas mal il ya un côté un peu tissu
un peu fibre on a bien l'écriture va
charge
hélas si on suit le chemin c'est ça que
jamais envoyé c'est tout cet univers
tout le travail qui est fait au niveau
de la boîte c'est une vraie découverte
c'est pas juste on ouvre on prend au
sort non il ya un vrai travail un vrai
parcours c'est vraiment réfléchi en tout
cas pour garder ma salle à vous avez un
petit message en plus gros hits the
weight bilan de cerfeuil ce qu'est ce
qu'on va voir ici une petite encoche
nova pour mieux ouvrir on ouvre et là on
tombe sur la coque ou un an +7 et pro
mac line avec un côté velours au centre
le côté légèrement arrondi ça fait
penser à un volant voyez on retrouve un
plus parce que vous en pensez dit le
moindre commentaire
moi j'aime pas ça qu'on est l'espèce de
forme de vos lampes il faut de plus le
branding à l'intérieur regardez le rendu
est pas mal ça vous donne donc en one +
7 t pro complètement customisé aux
couleurs de mclaren au travail qui a été
fait on retrouve ici le design intérieur
c'est vrai que c'est ce qui est toujours
dommage sur des smartphones comme ça
c'est tout le travail qui a été fait et
beck dès lors que vous mettez une comme
vous aller planquer s'est tarie roi plus
voir le dos alors c'est tout l'intérêt
c'est tout l'adn de ce produit d'avoir
un taux extrêmement rasées mais si vous
avez un smartphone comme ça que vous ne
protégez pas bien un moment où vous
risquez quand même certaines déconvenues
d'autant plus sur un smartphone qui
gagnent un certain budget le petit
bouton vont trouver sur le côté ici à la
même couleur pour nier en switch et si
vous voulez être en silencieux vibreur
comme d'habitude sur une puce va
retrouver je pense le petit message du
boss et invitational later c'est
toujours un peu le même parcours
on a un petit mot de pete merci pitt on
retrouve de courir notre tiroirs de
cartes sim tout une doc sans votre
smartphone pour tout savoir comment il
marche ca tous à tous avant ça c'est
cool temps j'ai l'impression de jouer au
jeu des 7 familles dans la famille one +
19 lequel vous voulez où je demande le
one + 7 t mince je les tiens c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de smartphones cette
année on a eu en début d'année le one +
7 le one + 7 pro et on se retrouvait
après avec loane plus c'est pts et le
one + 7 tétreault et là le one + 7
tétreault édition mclaren alors dans
tous ses smartphones vers lequel vous
dirigez vers lequel allaient le seul que
j'ai pas ici c'est le one piece est
ouest sera pas de tour d'horizon pour
regarder vers quel modèle se dirige est
surtout le vent de plus cet epr aux
éditions mclaren il fait le gros focus
en termes de performances
est ce qu'au final c'est vraiment un
modèle le plus performant si vous voulez
le top de la performance y voit une puce
est ce qu'il faut aller sur ce one + 7
et pro mclaren edition voici donc les
quatre smartphones que je vous présente
aujourd'hui one + 71 ou en plus cette
pro ou une poussette tpr au one piece
est des pros mclaren s'est mis les noms
ici l'idée c'est de faire un comparatif
pour essayer de se repérer savoir quel
smartphone est plus intéressant cette
année chez one piece alors je vous dis
une fois de plus j'ai supprimé le one
piece 7
je ne l'est pas c'est pour ça je voulais
pas inclus dans ce test mais très
clairement vous allez voir que déjà
quitte à choisir si vous posez la
question devant une puce est allé
directement sur une puce cette équipe a
un coût
le flagship killer de cette année va
donc ces quatre modèles quatre produits
relativement différent la première chose
qu'on va voir
geci de vous le faire comme ça pas
forcément évident vous avez des écrans
90 hertz de partout taux de
rafraîchissement qui apporte de la
fluidité
ça c'est vraiment cool le deuxième point
va se faire au terme de puissance et de
performances pures et dures à savoir que
vous avez sur tous les modèles sauf le
one + 7 pro instinct dragon 855 plus
c'est le socle le plus puissant de chez
qualcomm de cette année
néanmoins sur le wan plus elle prend
vous avez quand même 1 855 qui marche
très très bien je le remets dans les
courses par contre et c'est là que ça
devient très intéressant c'est que sur
le moins de plus 7 t vous avez 8 gigas
de ram plus 128 go de stockage sur le
web plus est prouvée choix 6 8 12 il ya
drame 128e du stockage 256 go de
stockage ou anne +7 tpr aux huit plus de
156 et lowan +7 des pros mclaren edition
12 plus 256 donc la gamme qu'on en cette
fin d'année est beaucoup plus simple 828
856 12 156 moi ici jeune modèle 12 256
donc j'ai exactement la même rame et le
même stockage que dans le mclaren
edition je vous ai fait un petit
benchmark en touche je vous montre ça à
la fin et vous allez voir c'est une
différence significative entre tous ces
modèles ensuite on continue
au niveau des batteries et de la
recharge il faut savoir que sur tous les
modèles de cette fin d'année sauf bien
évidemment sur le wan plus ces pros vous
avez de laval charge 30 et qui vous
permettra d'aller plus vite de le
recharger plus rapidement là déjà avec
la recharge 30 vous rechargez très
rapidement sur votre pc pts et vous avez
parlé de 3800 clients paire eur / le one
+ 7 pro 4000 millan paire eur et sur les
deux modèles ou en plus cette épreuve en
plus cet epr aux mclaren edition 4085
milliampères heures autant dire que tous
tient dans un mouchoir de poche et on
suit ce qui se passait au niveau des
tarifs et c'est là où c'est déjà très
intéressant et on voit que c'est
rapidement le bazar le one + 7 t c'est
le flagship killer par excellence il est
à 599 euros ou à être plus cette pro est
excellent par contre lui il devient
compliqué en termes de taille parce que
vous avez trois config différentes et
c'est là où ça fait un petit peu le
bazar on va revenir sur quelques
instants où elle +7 tpr au très bien
c'est un des modèles les plus
performants 759 euros est loin de plus
cet epr aux mclaren edition 859 euros
en gros vous avez 100 euros d'écart
entre le one piece est des pros et
nouvel opus cette épreuve mclaren
edition la différence et 8 gigas de ram
douzillac drame sinon c'est le design
matelas sont les finitions mclaren c'est
la partie software aussi mclaren je vous
montre ça dans quelques instants
en gros pour 100 euros d'écart est ce
que le fait d'avoir le nom apposé
mclaren le branding mclaren est ce que
le design mclaren va justifier pour vous
et notamment entre gilles adramé 12 il
est rappelé que le poids du matériel
sinon il ya quasiment pas de différence
mois contre 100 euros de différence
entre ces deux modèles c'est quand même
un gap qui est énorme pour avoir un
modèle mclaren après cela effectivement
vous êtes fan d'automobile mclaren vous
parle vous aimez les agneaux ce modèle
vous les payez avec 100 euros de plus la
petite différence au niveau de la ram
pour moi c'est pas ça qui va venir
justifier le tarif est là où ça devient
très intéressant c'est quand on va
comparer avec le one piece est propre
pour moi la version 6 giga de ram 100
étudiants de stockage à 709 euros à la
plus d'intérêt parce que vous allez
sûrement one + 70 vous avez un grand
écran bord à bord vous avez un écran 90
ans
vous avez une bonne batterie vous avez
une bonne autonomie vous avez lui giga
de ram au lieu de s'y joindre à vous
avez 100 étudiants du stockage en nuage
3.0 donc pour moi la config du one piece
est pro sys +128 celle là elle n'a
strictement plus aucun intérêt
après la question va se poser huit plus
256 on voit qu'on a le double stockage
par rapport aux opus septs et ça devient
intéressant par contre on a quand même
un gap de tarifs 599 759 c'est quand
même énorme
et si vous regardez bien et c'est là où
ça devient intéressant 8 plus de 156
vous le retrouvez sur une puce est des
pros
plus de 156 en gros vous avez la même
config au même prix donc quitte à mettre
le même prix avoir la même configuration
mieux vaut avoir un seul dragon 855 plus
4000 85 milliards d'euros batterie mais
c'est pas ça qui va venir changer
l'histoire de l'avare charge 30 thé et
surtout le dernier modèle avec la caméra
tôt donc cette config sur le wan plus
elle trop 856 elle n'a strictement plus
aucun intérêt non plus maintenant je
pose la question de la dernière config
12 plus 256 gigaoctets de stockage à 829
euros
eh bien voyez que l'on va venir flirter
avec le modèle mclaren qui lui est en
doute 156 à 859 euros
donc vous avez 30 euros d'écart pour
avoir le modèle mclaren avec la petite
caméra teuf avec les derniers
processeurs de qualcomm snapdragon 855
plus même si ça va pas changer grand
chose entre le 855 et illusions 55 plus
il ya pas un gros delta pareil pour moi
pour 30 euros d'écart avoir de la
recharge quand même plus rapide que ses
25 % plus rapide que le fait d'avoir le
design mclaren - vous voulez vraiment
allergique au design mclaren pour moi
c'est pareil le one plus c'est les pros
12 plus de 156 celui-là il disparaît il
a plus d'intérêt en gros cette nouvelle
gamme vient de dégager ce smartphone
purement et simplement ça aurait pu être
intéressant s'il y avait un tarif qui
était beaucoup plus bas et qui disait ok
on va garder le one + 7 pro dans la
gamme parce qu'il est bas parce que
tarifs les plus bas et du coup ce
intéressant pour moi du coup le one plus
ces pros il devient pas intéressant il
leur reviendra peut-être si son tarif
baisse c'est juste une question de
politique tarifaire presque le
smartphone est excellent il tient
quasiment les mêmes promesses que les
autres en termes de performances on si
on est quasiment sûr la même chose mais
en termes de tarifs
c'est plus très intéressant maintenant
il reste donc trois modèles en lice
trois modèles qui sont plus intéressants
alors pour les différencier c'est vite
vu vous allez voir le web + 71 c'est le
flagship killer par excellence c'est le
smartphone qu'il faut avoir si vous
voulez pas dépenser énormément et s'il
voulait ce qui est mis aujourd'hui sur
one plus à moins de 600 euros vous avez
un smartphone qui est vraiment top là
ont récemment dans l'adn de wang plus le
flat six de leurs abonnés vous parce
qu'on en reparle d'ici quelques jours
quant à la différence entre ces deux
modèles ont déjà dit juste avant ça
c'est à vous de voir en terme de goût
maintenant il ya un autre projet hyper
important hyper intéressant pour faire
votre choix entre ces différents modèles
c'est la partie performance parce que on
est sur des smartphones performants
là-dessus one plus fins très gros focus
avec les mclaren très clairement ils
vont chercher de la puissance de la
performance une
deux compères est ce qu'au final ce
match les rennais d'échelle mais une
claque aux autres j'en suis pas si sûr
regardez c'est là où ça vient vraiment
très très intéressant je vous a pris
exactement le même ordre one + 71 points
de plus cette pro en plus cette épreuve
en plus c'est très pro mclaren edition
dans l'ensemble les modèles se tiennent
en termes de performances pures et dures
on va contre stoke dragon 855 plus et
reste un dragon 855 voyez il n'y a pas
un delta alors là vous avez 8 giga drame
là vous avez 12 giga de ram
la ville est certes un dragon 855 plus 8
gigas de ram c'est un dragon 855 plus 12
giga de ram
c'est exactement la même machine ça va
porter une légère différence mais pas
grand chose tout ça ça se tient dans un
mouchoir de poche en termes de
performance vous avez quasiment la même
chose mais le modèle mclaren laraque un
intérêt parce qu'il a un dos qui est
vraiment très différenciant et très
jolie il a aussi un intérêt au niveau de
l' os qui a été retravaillé justement
pour le modèle à savoir vous avez des
icônes qui sont différentes dans les
couleurs correspondent aux modèles en
fond d'écran qui est adapté et lorsque
vous allez dans vos paramètres y est
tout est complètement adapté au modèle
de mclaren ou one piece est très pro mac
les radiers pouvait venir en plus
personnaliser votre fond d'écran votre
horloge l'horloge qui aussi l'horloge du
modèle en fait un vrai travail qui a été
fait aussi au niveau de l'ouest pour
avoir une expérience complète au niveau
du modèle mclaren lohan tous ces petits
pros mclaren édition est vachement
intéressant si vous aimez mclaren si
vous voulez un modèle atypique si vous
voulez un modèle aux couleurs de mclaren
si vous êtes fan de la marque
il est effectivement le modèle du mois
de plus le plus performant mais il n'est
pas du tout une claque aux autres c'est
normal parce que votre plus a déjà mis
la barre très très haute en terme de
space si vous voulez un modèle
extrêmement parfois moins sur une plus
beau ballet sur le même concept et pro
qui est déjà extrêmement performant qui
coûte quand même 100 euros de moins cher
mais si vous voulez faire plaisir
si vous aimez mclaren si vous aimez la
marque si vous aimez le design si vous
aimez ce qu'il propose la valeur qu'ils
vont proposer et bien couvert et sur le
one + 7 pro mclaren edition vous mettrez
100 euros de plus c'est un certain
budget mais à côté de ça vous avez un
truc qui coule moi je sais pas ce que je
trouve pas mal dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire est ce
qu'il vous plaît souvent de plus cette
épreuve mclaren edition le nom et
longboard lcd nom à rallonge
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la gamme de
cette année est ce que vous êtes
satisfait par les versions pro qui sont
arrivés est ce que vous pensez tout
comme moi que le one + 71 c'est le
flagship killer par excellence seul truc
qui fait que ce modèle j'aurai un petit
bémol c'est l'encoche nous ont pas il
fallait bien différencier modèle vous
êtes tous des modèles
les grands écrans là vous avez une
petite encoche armés tirer les prix vers
le bas j'ai pas mettre ce mécanisme de
caméras pop up
mais voilà quand on a goûté au grand
écran sans encoches on se dit c'est
toujours un petit peu dommage d'avoir eu
à côté de ça le smartphone est vachement
cool et très intéressant avoue de médias
maintenant ce que vous en pensez
comment vous trouvez celui là vous
marrer tout ça on va en commentaire
quant à nous on se retrouve dès demain
on a plein de belles choses à se
raconter vous embrasse des mecs et
demain ciao